>> Well, good afternoon
everyone at the lunchbox.
Welcome to another exciting
Musicians@Google event.
We are very very pleased
today to have the, umm,
premier at Google of
a band 16 Frames.
They are here on, uh, talking
about their new debut album,
was called "Where It Ends."
The main song featured on that
is the single "Back Again"
which came out yesterday.
So we're very lucky to have the
live demo here at the Lunchbox.
So, the band has received much
critical acclamation as well.
They've received attention
and had many of their songs
featured on various shows
from MTV's "The Hills"
to ABC's "Private Practice"
and their singles are also
a huge hit on YouTube
and on Myspace.
So what I thought I'd do first
is give a brief introduction
to the band while I take a few
general questions and answers
and then we'll let them launch
into their show,
and afterwards we'll
have some time for
some Q and A from the audience.
So first, gentlemen, would you,
like to go ahead
and introduce yourselves?
Daniel: Hello.
I'm Daniel.
Nice to meet all of you.
Steve: Hello.
I'm Steve.
Nice to meet all of you.
Josh: I'm Josh.
Steve: And, actually, Dylan,
our bass player, is not here.
He's in L.A. right now so--
so you just get
three out of the four.
You get 12 Frames.
[laughing]
>> So, tell me how you all
got started.
Steve: Umm, I wrote a group
of songs
and I started recording --
I started recording the record
on my own, and then I met Josh
and Josh came in on the project.
As we worked together,
uh, we brought Daniel.
We brought Daniel, so kind
of sort of kinda like a
"Field of Dreams"if you build it into a concert they will come.
So the band was sort of built
around the making of the record.
So by the time the album was
done, 16 Frames performed.
>> Awesome.
Awesome.
So, how would you describe
your musical influences
and have they changed since
you're forming the band
and recording the album?
Steve: Uh, why don't you
talk a little bit about that?
Josh: I don't know
if they've changed.
I've been listening to Verve,
and Travis, and Coldplay,
and Oasis.
I could go on
forever -- Beatles.
For quite a long time,
I think it just continues.
The band I end up liking
adding all new
and also effect that kind of things.
Carolina Liar.
Listened to them today.
>> Awesome.
How about you, Daniel?
Daniel: You took the words
right out of my mouth.
Travis, U2, Coldplay, uh --
Steve: Actually --
Daniel: -- Beatles.
Steve: See, my first influence
was Elvis Presley
and Elvis Presley introduced
me to music
and then there's the Beatles.
The Beatles sort of made me
look at song writing
and really helped me get interested in
being a song writer,
not just enjoying music,
and bands like The Laws, U2,
those bands sort of showed me about emotion
and how you could really put
all that together.
So those four different bands
or artists really
sort of formed who I am as a --
as a writer and an artist.
>> All right.
Very cool.
And speaking of things that are
in force, we got, you know,
16 Frames is the name
of your band as well.
How'd you come up with the name?
Steve: Uh, 16 frames
is a film term.
When I write songs I --
I can see the -- the --
like, I can see the guitar lines,
I can see the lyric.
It's like a weird thing.
So it's very visual to me.
So, you know, whenever I'm
writing a song I'm trying to --
trying to put it together
and finding that moment where everything makes sense.
Sort of like that moment
of epiphany,
getting the moment that
it all flows,
and, uh, 16 frames per second
approximately is that moment
where the image to
the naked eye becomes
sort of the most choppy
in terms of fluid motion.
So to me that sort of represents
that moment
where everything makes sense
and me, uh, approach
the music that way,
we approach working
on a live show.
Everything sort of --
we sort of --
that's sort of our approach
to everything.
Making a record, writing a
song, working on a live set.
It's finding that place where
everything makes sense
from beginning to end.
>> Okay. Cool. Well, tell me more about making the record.
How'd you bring everything
together
and any fun stories
from recording?
Steve: Fun stories?
>> Or touring.
Steve: Or touring?
We have fun touring stories.
But we probably don't wanna
talk about those. [laughing]
Steve: No.
Daniel: You gotta be
politically correct.
Steve: That's right.
We're trying to get fans,
not lose them.
Now, uh, making the record
there was --
it's the process is really about
writing the songs for the record
and, uh, that's where
it all started.
I wrote a song called
"Back Again" and that sort of
was that moment for me
where I realized
that's where I wanted
to be as a song writer,
that's where I wanted the vibe
of the songs to be
and at least sort
of built around that.
And, uh, I would get up
every morning at 10:00 a.m.,
I'd write 'til noon, have lunch,
write 'til dinner time,
uh, eat dinner, and then write
till, like, one in the morning.
I did it every day and then, umm,
then when I was finished
at the end of the day
I would watch DVDs, and I would
watch "No Direction Home",
it's a Dylan documentary,
uh, great Dylan documentary.
There's one I think it's called
"Wings for Wheels"
I don't know if I have
the name right
but it was about the making
of Warren Robins
and Bruce Springsteen
documentary
and, uh, I watch old Dick Cavett shows on DVD,
so I would see, like,
Janice Joplin, George Harrison,
Paul Simon, and you'd watch
all these performances,
Sly and the Family Stone,
so I would do that every night.
And so I'd work all day --
write all day --
and then I'd watch the stuff
at night as kinda like fuel
to get up the next day
and sort of inspiration.
Not that any of the
music sounds like Dylan.
I wish -- I wish I could write
lyrics like Dylan, but-
but I think it's one
of those things
you draw inspiration from your heroes.
>> Awesome.
Awesome.
And, uh, and you -- of course,
your video is very popular
on your MySpace
and YouTube sites.
Tell me a little bit about, umm,
filming the video
with the 16 Frames.
Steve: Filming the video?
Daniel: Umm, David Gelb
directed it,
a really talented young director.
Umm, we got to shoot it
in downtown Los Angeles
at this, uh, what was it?
Like,
a woodcutting shop
or something--
Steve: Some kinda warehouse.
Daniel: A lot of sawdust
on the ground.
Really cool.
Like, they had these --
the whole side of the building
was, like, wood slats.
So, uh, like, literally when
we came in we got in at,
like, six in the morning,
the sun was coming through.
So when you watch the video
and you see, like, the cool,
they literally had, like,
the sawdust, like
everything in the air
you can see the sun
coming through the side.
And just really beautiful video,
cool -- really cool video.
Steve: Yeah. So about 6:30 in the morning we're performing.
In order to get all the
natural light in there.
It looks amazing but --
>> Well, that's a good time. Steve: Yeah. 6:30.
We're normally up
at five or six.
>> Yeah. That's what I expected.
Steve: But that was
a great experience.
It was a great -- we
had a great director.
Daniel: Really talented
director.
Steve: Yeah. And he did a great job editing it
and putting it all together,
and we were really happy
with the end result.
>> Awesome.
So I know right now we got
our concert going on
at the Lunchbox here at Google
but what's next for 16 Frames after this awesome show?
Steve: Later today we're gonna
have some lunch here
and then we're gonna go for
a drive down the coast.
Now, you know, we're putting
together a tour
so we'll be coming back around
spring/summer.
We're working out the
details for that now.
We're doing promotional
stuff right now.
You know, our album
came out yesterday.
We're really, really
excited about it.
We're a new band on
Verve Universal
and we're really happy that Google --
that you guys are having us
come here and play for your --
your lunch.
>> Awesome.
Steve: And this --
and that's what's next
and we're finishing off
some promotional stuff.
We're working on some other
songs for some --
maybe for some future B signs
and then we're gonna be hitting
the road.
>> Cool. Well, why don't you
go ahead and give us
a sample of your work.
And ladies and gentlemen
at the Lunchbox,
I proudly present 16 Frames. Steve: Oh, thank you.
[applause]
Steve: Okay, guys. So,
this is-- obviously
this is the first time
that you guys have had bands come in.
This is our first coming here
so,
uh, we'd like to tell you
a little bit about ourselves
but we've already done that so
why don't we play some songs?
This song is a --
the first song on the --
on the album and, uh,
it's, uh, it pretty much sets
the tone for the record which -
[strum strum]
Steve: -- is a breakup record
and every song sort of deals
with it at different angles.
This one is, uh,
called "Close Range"
and, uh,
I was -- my --
my, uh --
a friend of mine, you know,
called me up one night.
His girlfriend was just,
for whatever reason
she's just, like,
not in a good mood
and she's like nothing's wrong.
Nothing's wrong.
And she just went to bed
and he just called me up
and he's freaking out
'cause he was really suspicious.
He had no idea why.
And, uh, I really didn't know
what to say to him but
when I got off the phone I wrote
this song and I thought it was a
I wanna thank him for the father of the song.
It's called "Close Range."
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ First you fall in love.
♪ then you make it.
♪ when you've had enough.
♪ you start to fake it.
♪ with someone on the phone.
♪ But you're not listening.
♪ And she's not coming home.
♪ Remember when you met.
♪ so picture perfect.
♪ She's meeting all your friends.
♪ because its worth it.
♪ And they can only see.
♪ What you cannot see.
The things you won't believe.
♪ Then you wake up to the big
change.
♪ To the break up.
♪ Done at close range.
♪ And that love is such
a cruel thing.
♪ What you want, you got.
♪ But you can't hold on anymore.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ You ask her what is
wrong.
♪ She can't explain it.
♪ It's something that was strong.
♪ Just started fading.
♪ But everything's alright.
♪ But you believe her.
♪ She turns off the lights.
♪ When the morning comes.
♪ It's when it hits you.
♪ She's standing all alone.
♪ Saying she'll miss you.
♪ There's someone at the door.
♪ Because she's leaving.
♪ You fall into the floor.
♪ Then you wake up to
the big change.
♪ To the break up.
♪ Done at close range.
♪ And that love is such
a cruel thing.
♪ What you want, you got.
♪ But you can't hold on anymore.
I said best of luck.
♪ They said easier than done.
♪ Best of luck I said easier
ba ba ba ba.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: [Singing slowly]
♪ Oo oo.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: [Singing slowly]
♪ Oo oo.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: [Singing slowly] Oo oo.
Steve: ♪ Then you wake up to the big change.
♪ To the break up.
♪ Done at close range.
♪ And that love is such
a cruel thing.
♪ What you want, you got.
♪ But you can't hold on.
♪ Then you wake up
to the big change.
♪ To the break up.
♪ Done at close range.
♪ And that love is such
a cruel thing.
♪ What you want, you got.
♪ But can't hold on anymore.
♪ You can't hold on anymore.
♪ What you want, you got. ♪
♪ [playing chord on guitar]
[applause]
Steve: Is that enjoyable?
It was enjoyable for me.
>> Yeah.
Steve: Was that good?
I think I need to warm up.
[strum strum]
Steve: So, uh --
Daniel: Fa fa phooey.
Sue sue su-yo.
Steve: So we're pretty much,
just wondering, you guys.
There's no time limit.
You can come in and have lunch
as long as you want,
hang out 45 minutes, half hour.
This is not the normal --
we've been doing a lot
of shows going
and playing for, like, corporate
kinda things or whatever you wanna call it but this is, like,
really laid back so
this is kinda what you do?
As long as you want, free food? [laughing]
Daniel: Life is good at Google.
Steve: Is the keg of beer
normally here? [laughing]
>> Always.
[laughing]
Steve: It really helps
the productivity.
[laughing]
[strum strum]
Steve: Josh.
Steve: I'm gonna tell you
about this song.
This song --
how many --
I'm -- I live in California.
I live in LA but I'm not really
from LA like a lot of people.
I'm originally from Massachusetts and, uh,
small town.
There's pretty much a keg of
beer in everyone's room
where I came from.
[laughing]
Steve: And so I kinda had
had to get away
and make my own life.
And I was really interested
in music
and I wanted to see
what I could do.
So I left.
And, uh, subsequently it's
really hard to go back.
I -- never go back.
For whatever reason there's
just something there
I didn't wanna go back to
and I finally did
after a few years,
went back on Thanksgiving.
And it sort of like came back
to the same situations,
same lifestyle, everything --
everything was the same
and it was, uh, hard to see,
hard to deal with and, uh,
I ended up writing this song about it,
a song called "Coming Home."
[People chatting in
the background]
[playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ Sorry that I don't come around here very often.
♪ My number changed and I forgot
to let you know just where I am.
♪ It's too late to bring this up
♪ and anyway I've had enough
for today.
♪ It's good to see you again.
♪ 'Cause you know you're
not the only one.
♪ Who's been living
with the damage done.
♪ It's hard to hide the
pain of coming home.
♪ When you standing right
in front of me.
♪ With all the things
I have to leave.
♪ It's hard to hide the pain
of coming home.
♪ It's hard to hide the
pain of coming home.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ I'm feeling like
I don't belong with you,
♪ here where I started.
♪ The days are gone when I would
watch and tear
♪ all our dreams apart.
♪ Honestly, I don't regret
the urgency of
♪ how I left with no warning.
♪ But you had to see it coming.
♪ 'Cause you know you're
not the only one.
♪ Who's been living with
the damage done.
♪ It's hard to hide the
pain of coming home.
♪ When you standing right
in front of me.
♪ With all the things
I have to leave.
♪ It's hard to hide the pain
of coming home.
♪ It's hard to hide the
pain of coming home.
♪ So, this place is
full of broken hearts.
♪ I'd really love to put
them together again.
♪ I've got to watch out
for myself.
♪ 'Cause we've all lost something.
♪ We've been hanging on.
♪ And it won't take
much to break us.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ 'Cause you know you're
not the only one.
♪ Who's been living
with the damage done.
♪ It's hard to hide the
pain of coming home.
♪ When you standing right
in front of me.
♪ With all the things
I have to leave.
♪ It's hard to hide the pain
of coming home.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ They say home
is where the heart is.
♪ Home is where my little is.
♪ Home is where my heart is.
Oh yeah.
[playing guitar music slowly]
[applause]
Steve: So, uh, this song is, uh,
encapsulates the record I think.
I told you before,
it's a breakup record,
11 songs dealing with the
subject from different angles.
This one is the, uh,
the Dear John.
Imagine getting up in the
morning and writing a letter,
leaving, and taking off.
Uh, that's what this is.
"My History".
♪ [playing guitar music]
Steve: ♪ When you wake up
and you read this
♪ You have to know that
I really mean it
♪ You're just a memory,
you're just a memory
♪ Of a long road that
got too hard
♪ And the more we go the more
that it hurt us
♪ So as a friend to me,
as a friend to me
♪ Let those feelings go I said
until everything is gone
♪ You and I we know our history
♪ Let those feelings go I said because everyone moves on
♪ 'Cause you and I we know
our history
♪ So was it all bad or
was it all good?
♪ Was someone in between
Well really what isn't?
♪ Think what you wanna think
You can think what
you wanna think
♪ About the love we had
It was so much work
♪ The thrill is gone So what have we got left?
♪ I don't wanna change
for me yeah.
♪ I don't wanna change for you.
♪ Let those feelings go I said
until everything is gone
♪ 'Cause you and I we know
our history
♪ So let those feelings go I said because everyone moves on
♪ 'Cause you and I we know
our history
♪ It's on my mind
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ Oh...
♪ So let those feelings go I said until everything is gone
♪ You and I we know our history
♪ Let those feelings go I said because every one moves on
♪ We know our history
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ Oh oh.
Stay. Stay.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
[applause]
[Strumming guitar]
Steve: So, we're gonna play a
song that we normally don't play
but it's on the album.
It's a great song.
It's called "Let's Not Pretend."
We've been going around,
we've been doing, like,
little acoustics set for,
like, you know,
different people, different -- different stuff
and, uh, we haven't played
this one.
But we thought
we'd give it a try.
This is a song that
when I wrote I thought
this is the greatest song
I've ever written.
I was so excited about it.
We pretty much think that
after every song you write
but you listen to it a day later
and you're, like, maybe not.
Maybe I was wrong about
that one.
But, no. This song I've
always loved and, uh,
and, uh, I really was --
you know, I thought that
I was stretching myself
in my song writing
when I wrote this one.
We've, uh, been fortunate to
have a place on some television
shows and stuff to see it,
like, to see, like, a --
a, you know, moving images
and this was the show
Howard's Way and it was a movie.
Characters are like a
big kiss or whatever.
To see the song in
a setting like that
was a really gratifying thing.
But anyways we're gonna
play it for you right now.
It's called "Let's Not Pretend."
[playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ Gravity is pulling
you in
♪ Cause the earth it won't stop
spinning
♪ It's no surprise.
♪ You found me again
♪ After all it was the best
thing that we ever had
♪ Now sugar, I can see you honey
♪ Ooouuuu let's not pretend
that it's here babe
♪ The world that we know
disappeared long ago.
♪ 'Cause we just couldn't
carry the weight
[playing guitar music slowly]
♪ I know you all,
want someone to care
♪ To find the words when
you can not find them yourself
♪ The things you lost,
you'll never get back
♪ It's too late, you're just
gonna drag out the past
♪ Now sugar,
I can't see you honey
♪ Ooouuuu let's not pretend
that it's here babe
♪ The world that we know disappeared long ago.
♪ 'Cause we just couldn't
carry the weight
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ This time what are
you searching for
♪ The better days you
thought you had before.
♪ So what if you don't
see it anymore
♪ Can you hear what I say-
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ Oh yes now sugar,
I can see you honey
♪ Ooouuuu let's not pretend
that it's here babe
♪ The world that
we know disappeared long ago.
♪ 'Cause we just couldn't carry.
♪ Ooouuuu let's not pretend
that it's here babe
♪ The world that we know disappeared long ago.
♪ 'Cause we just couldn't
carry the weight
♪ Just couldn't carry the weight
♪ Just couldn't carry ohh
♪ Just couldn't carry ahh
♪ Just couldn't carry ahh.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
[applause]
Steve: Thank you.
Daniel: Some new picks.
Some sweet picks.
[laughing]
Instead of actually listening
to us they're watching it --
watching it on YouTube. [laughing]
Whatever. Technology.
[laughing]
Steve: We'd like to play a
couple more songs for you.
So hopefully you're
enjoying the performance.
I hope you're having a good
time. [applause]
Steve: So, today we're looking
at the actual --
the, uh -- where it ends is
actually the name of the album.
I think we have some for you
so if -- do we have any, Doug?
Daniel: If you haven't gotten
received an album, umm --
Steve: Please. We're giving them away for free.
Daniel: We'll have 'em for you. Come talk to us.
Steve: And then actually get
the physical copy --
copy of it and then go,
you know, buy it, too,
because we are a new band.
[laughing]
Steve: I'm just kidding.
But we have CDs.
Take a CD, listen to it,
tell your friends,
and we're gonna play you a song
called "Where It Ends".
This is the title
track from the record.
And surprisingly enough,
it's a breakup song.
If you were listening,
they're all breakup songs.
[Strumming guitar]
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ Look at me,
I'm not what you need
If you think that I should catch
you everytime you fall
I have tried, but there are
too many places you hide
This is gonna hurt you.
I never meant to hurt you.
I don't wanna see you fall.
But I can't be holdin' on
To the same mistakes
we always make.
And here's where it ends.
Whoa.
Ohhh.
So tell me that.
Do you understand?
There's no way we
could ever be the same.
[playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ This is gonna hurt you.
♪ I never meant to hurt you.
♪ I don't wanna see you fall.
♪ But I can't be holdin' on
♪ To the same mistakes
we always make.
♪ And here's where it ends.
♪ Ohh, ohh.
♪ Here's where it ends.
♪ It ends, it ends.
♪ For you and me.
♪ It ends, now that
it ends, it ends.
♪ So tell me that.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
♪ Do you understand?
There's no way that we
could ever be the same.
And this is gonna hurt you.
I never meant to hurt you.
'Cause I'm going away.
I don't wanna see you fall
But I can't be holdin' on
To the same mistakes we always make.
And here's where...
Ohh ohh.
Here's where...
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
[applause]
Steve: All right guys.
Well, thank you very much
for having us.
We'd like to play you one more.
[Strumming guitar]
>> Will you be giving out CDs to anyone who asks you a question?
Steve: CDs?
Questions?
After this song we'll
do more Q and A.
We'll set at your table
and talk with you.
Get you a CD.
Definitely get a CD.
>> Do they get a CD if
they ask you a question?
Steve: Yes. We'll give 'em a CD if they ask a question?
If you ask for a CD
I guess that's requesting a question though, right?
Get a CD. Ask a question,
don't ask a question.
This song is back again
this is the single.
It's coming out now.
It's starting to
get on the radio.
We're really excited
about it and, uh,
this is one we made
the video for.
[Strumming guitar]
Steve: This is the one that
got us the record deals.
Daniel: This is the big
one, people.
This is the --
Steve: Greatest song ever
written.
Daniel: -- big deal.
[laughing]
Steve: You guys ready
to soft rock?
[laughing]
Steve: All right.
[Strumming guitar]
♪ [playing guitar music slowly, drum beat coming from laptop]
Steve: ♪ When the fire's burned out of me.
♪ And the tears start
drowning me.
♪ I'm with you
Right here from the start.
♪ Is where we'll fall apart.
♪ What you do is still
not good enough.
♪ You're feeling sick because
you've had too much.
♪ I'm with you
Right here from the start.
♪ Is where we'll fall apart
Is where we'll fall apart.
♪ We'll get it back again.
♪ Set on the track again.
♪ Soon enough we'll know.
♪ See what you left behind.
♪ Take it as good advice.
♪ That you and I can't hold.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ So what you feel
is not workin out.
♪ And what you say
is not coming out.
♪ I'm with you
Right here from the start.
♪ Is where we'll fall apart
Is where we'll fall apart.
♪ We'll get it back again.
♪ Set on the track again.
♪ Soon enough we'll know.
♪ We'll see what you left behind.
♪ Take it as good advice.
♪ That you and I can't hold.
♪ Well now anyway.
♪ It really doesn't matter
anymore.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ Well now anyway.
♪ It really doesn't matter
anymore.
♪ Ohh...
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ I'm with you.
Right here from the start.
♪ Is where we fall apart
Is where we fall apart.
♪ We'll get it back again.
♪ Set on the track again.
♪ Soon enough we'll know.
♪ See what you left behind.
♪ Take it as good advice.
♪ That you and I, you and I...
♪ And we'll get it back again.
♪ Set on the track again.
♪ And soon enough we'll know
♪ We'll take all the books
you read.
♪ Use them as evidence.
♪ That you and I can't hold Ohhh.
♪ Ohhh.
♪ Won't you say what you
want me to say
♪ And then be what you want me
to see, love.
♪ To be love
♪ To be love.
♪ Ohhh.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: Thank you very much, guys.
[applause]
>> Y'all don't have one more?
Come on.
Daniel: One more?
>> One more.
>> Come on.
One more guys?
[clapping]
Daniel: I don't really know.
I don't know what else.
Here you go.
I'll do a cover of Six
Pence None The Richer.
[laughing]
Daniel: ♪ Kiss me out of
the bearded barley.
♪ Lightly...
[laughing]
Daniel: Just kidding.
[Strumming guitar]
>> Amazing. [laughing]
Steve: I shall play another one
that we normally don't play.
This is not on the album.
It -- it was on the album --
Daniel: This is exclusively
for Google live. [laughing]
Steve: It'll be at
some point but, uh,
I'm not sure if we can actually
know how to play it
but you're not gonna know
the difference so hey.
[laughing]
[Strumming guitar]
Steve: It's called "Fool".
>> Fool.
[Strumming guitar]
>> Is this a breakup song?
Steve: It needs to be
a breakup song.
>> Sound like a breakup song.
Steve: When we play
this electrically,
this is one of our favorite
songs to play electrically.
Umm, nobody else really
seems to like it but we do.
If you asked for one more,
we're gonna play it.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ You loved me
♪ I held you high so high
I lost you anyway.
♪ I couldn't be the one to stop
the rain and keeping you away.
♪ Isn't it easier in time?
♪ That won't save me now.
♪ I was your fool.
♪ Hey hey.
♪ Your fool.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ I let the days roll
by always knew
♪ that I would keep you safe.
♪ How could I be so blind trying
to read every move you made?
♪ Isn't it easier in time?
♪ That won't save me now.
♪ I was your fool.
♪ Hey hey.
♪ Your fool.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ Whoa.
Steve: ♪ I was your fool.
♪ Whoa.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ I was your fool.
Hey hey.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
Steve: ♪ It should be someone else.
♪ Why do I feel and why
does it feel strange?
♪ I could get so strung out
♪ trying to read every move
you made.
♪ Things will get easier in time
but that won't save me now.
♪ I was your fool.
♪ Your fool.
♪ Hey hey. Hey hey. Hey hey.
♪ [playing guitar music slowly]
[applause]
Steve: Thank you.